you know you might as well shoot for
something large because you can still
end up with something smaller
but aiming for something large is really
important when I went to all my smart
friends and asked them they basically
two-thirds of them said I was an idiot
entrepreneurship is a team sport more
than it is an individual sport that if
you're gonna actually kind of pack up
your wagons and go somewhere make sure
that where you're going is potentially
really good the number of companies that
really matter every year is probably
between zero and five frequently
entrepreneurs I know it's a secret my I
have a hidden idea go and talk to people
about it this is my main plan if that's
hitting problems like I'm not growing
fast enough or I'm stalling out okay
here are some things I can try to keep
trying to do that every valuable startup
has a has weeks and months of valley of
the shadow which is why did I ever think
this was a good idea we have this
expression in the valley called fail
fast sometimes you find yourself you
know pioneering going that you can't
find a way through the mountains he's an
American internet entrepreneur venture
capitalist and author he's the
co-founder and executive chairman of
LinkedIn he has an estimated net worth a
four point six billion dollars
he's Reid Hoffman and here his top ten
rules for success it's the same amount
of blood sweat and tears when you start
a company whether or not it's it's kind
of a you know kind of a fixed vertical
market or whether or not it's something
really really large and the difference
is is is that you know you might as well
shoot for something large because you
can still end up with something smaller
but aiming for something large is really
important and part of the reason why
this is kind of a rule of
entrepreneurship and maybe this is the
kind of thing that to this room is like
yeah we all know this we're living it I
hope is because the if you if you don't
start out aiming for the big game you
almost never can get there it's got to
be the kind of the how do I have kind of
global impact like I think all
high-impact
companies are basically have to think
globally in nature these days because of
the way that the the market ecosystem is
going and so you go ok how do i how do I
play onto that stage
and you know part of that in terms of a
pioneer parallels again how do I go
somewhere that is that is that it's
substantial and unique for example when
I started LinkedIn and I went to all
Mike because you should go to all your
smart friends and ask them when I went
to all my smart friends and asked them
they basically two-thirds of them said I
was 80 an idiot for starting like Tim it
was like this is a crazy idea that some
that's a good signal right and the
reason it's a good signal is because of
a hundred percent of people think it's
good there's almost always problems that
you're not seeing and that enough other
people think it's good too that the
competition pile around it is serious so
I like the fact that you say why would
smart people think this is not a good
idea but actually in fact there's
something that makes it a good idea even
despite that entrepreneurship is a team
sport
more than it is an individual sport
people obviously celebrate the
individual heroic entrepreneur and the
the stories tend to be told in
retrospect but most successful
entrepreneurship projects actually have
two to three founders sometimes even
five although two to three is standards
so make sure that you have that solid
initial founders that your co-founders
and the team around you and your your
journey is almost certainly gonna lead
you through what I call the valley of
the shadow so that means that you should
have a strong enough relationship with
your founders that it will pressure test
in difficult times look for disruptive
change and the reason that I said look
for disruptive change is because it's
what are the opportunities that come out
that are really new opportunities that
are something and because the
opportunity generally speaking has to be
large it can't be something like well
boy you know it's been sitting there for
10 or 20 years and no one's ever really
thought about it that's very rarely the
right answer and if it's not large
enough to to be something that that you
could you could make something
significant out of it's not really high
impact and the kind of pioneer parallel
to this is that if you're gonna actually
kind of pack up your wagons and go
somewhere make sure that where you're
going is potentially really good
right and that the algorithm by which
you can you can think about that is all
of a sudden there's a new opportunity
it's a change in technology it's a
change in competitive landscape it's a
change in and kind of how the global
ecosystem comes together the number of
companies that really matter every year
is probably between 0 and 5 right in
terms of like the industry changing so
you look at an audience like this which
is what 1,400 people 1,700 people you
say it's an average of two founders per
company's presume everyone's doing it
you got 850 in the room right and so
then that's only the people who are here
let alone everything else and so the
question is is how do you break through
the noise is a really really key thing
whether it's financing talent
aggregation go to market etc so how that
then becomes a central problem so one of
them is is to say well do something very
contrarian do something that is kind of
like not like where people say well you
know it's it's it's Airbnb but for dogs
right you know or that kind of thing is
not the kind of thing to do
generally right it's a very rare that
that's ever become the big companies yes
extremely rare the second thing would be
is to look we're really look we're and
there's one of the reasons why both you
and I are fans of Peters question of you
know what do you believe that other
people don't but look where other people
really aren't right like whether it's
you know hard science or if it was two
and a half years ago Bitcoin you know
etc you know those sorts of things were
like well actually something could be
really big here because by the way if
you end up being right you end up having
access the talent that's really it's
really focused on that you have a ramp
to actually get a whole bunch of stuff
and get a big head start from other
possible competitive efforts and these
sorts of things you want to get a good
sense of whether or not you're on track
or on target to where you're moving and
so one of the things that Chris Ben and
I write about in the Alliance called
Network intelligence which is the get as
much intelligence about your project as
possible so frequently entrepreneurs say
oh it's a secret my I have a hidden idea
go and talk to people about it get their
feedback on it don't necessarily publish
it to the web
but to go get that feedback in order to
know how to adjust your plan how to know
what the market is how to note the
weather looks like you know these sorts
of things in order to be successful and
do that literally anyone who's smart who
will talk to you talk to them get that
feedback to maintain flexible
persistence and entrepreneurs are given
two pieces of advice with equal vigor
where you look at them they're in contra
they're in contradiction one is have a
vision you know plow through the wall
keep your vision you know don't allow
yourself to be defocused from that keep
going the other one is listen your
customers listen the market feedback
listen your network you know be really
adaptive you're like well okay I you
know you know how do you put those two
things together and that's part of again
where it's a very difficult thing to
teach other than by doing right other
than by the activity of going out and
being an entrepreneur and and making
those decisions and so the reason that
the rule is maintain flexible
persistence is because it's both keep a
vision and be flexible so for example if
you think about the kind of the abz
planning framework it's like look I've
got a plan I want to try to get there
this is my main plan if that's hitting
problems like I'm not growing fast
enough or I'm stalling out okay here are
some things I can try to keep trying to
do that and if that doesn't work how do
I shift to a different destination a
different location that's part of the
plan Z one of the paradoxes
entrepreneurship is you do these kind of
two things that are in contradiction in
balance so one of them is you actually
want to have some self delusion about
yes I'm sure I can make it work on the
other hand you want to be asking
yourself every day and every every week
is my confidence in this going up or
down and if it's not going up what do I
need to do and learn and pivot in order
to get in order to have it and it
doesn't have to be that goes up every
week I mean PayPal LinkedIn we've had
weeks every valuable startup has a has
weeks and months of valley of the shadow
which is why did I ever think this was a
good idea and so that happened so the
confidence can go down that's fine but
you've got but part of the reason you're
asking this question is in order to know
what problem do I need to tackle
aggressively to think that I'm on the
right path we have this expression in
called fail fast really what that is is
be measuring the confidence interval the
confidence in your investment thesis and
what you're doing and be measuring that
in a way that when you when it begins
decreasing and decreases substantially
like again and again over time to pivot
to change and you want to be getting as
much early data as much early feedback
it isn't even also data it could be
perspective to know whether or not your
plan is gonna work or not so that you
can adjust early because if you stay oh
I just have my vision and I'm gonna work
on this for seven years you could
frequently be nowhere where is if you
had if you had taken Network
intelligence and you had adjusted your
plan as you were going you could end up
being very successful a plan for both
good and bad luck and part of what it is
is people say what do you mean plan for
good luck you know I had this idea you
know it works out and then I and then
things keep going well good luck
actually comes in opportunities that you
don't you don't normally you don't
normally see so for example PayPal
started as a encryption on mobile phones
company because it was two close friends
of mine I joined the board when they
found it even though I thought
encryption technology and mobile phones
back in December 9 ta twas a was a not a
good idea which I told them that it was
kind of like you also back people and
then they were like well okay not not
encryption of all phones maybe cache
some old phones or maybe not just cash
to mobile phones maybe cash on Palm
Pilots maybe cash on Palm Pilots and
peanuts service to the web and then they
launched with that and for the first
week they said well all this growth is
is coming through eBay but that's not
really what we planned we planned on
people like bringing their Palm Pilot
around with them exchanging money you
know these aren't our customers we
should figure out how to get them off
and then of course part of PayPal's
great strength was being able to pivot
fast and then went oh oh no these are
our customers right all the rest of that
stuff doesn't work this is this is the
thing that we need to go to and that's
an instance of what I think of as
planning for good luck
which is you basically you go okay
sometimes what happens when you start
the journey of going down to companies
you're looking for an opportunity that
you may not recognize Easter dit but
then suddenly you kind of you know like
the pioneering parallel you come around
the corner and all of a sudden there's
new opportunities available to you and
that you head very strongly to that and
so good luck is not just oh look my plan
worked it's you will encounter
opportunities that you will need to move
quickly and grow into an exploit by
having been on the journey now planning
for bad luck is unfortunately a little
bit more straightforward which is
sometimes you find yourself you know
pioneering going that you can't find a
way through the mountains how do what a
year what's your plan B right and one of
the ways that I frequently think about
this is I kind of have a plan a a plan
being a plan Z the plan a is okay this
is what we're think you're doing Plan B
is well if that's not working what are
my parameters of flexibility I'm still
trying to get to that's the the same you
know build the same product the same
product market fit I'm still trying to
get there but maybe if I try this rather
than that and so for example when I when
we launched LinkedIn you know our hope
was that people would just invite each
other and and the invitations would work
and it would grow in a big network and
and you know and that that would be all
we need to do in order to grow the
network well as it turned out we
launched the network and you know and a
couple weeks later we're growing at
2,000 people a week and I was like wow
that's not fast enough so what were the
other ideas we had in mind the kind of
plan B and the plan B was well actually
if we one of the questions that people
most have when they come to LinkedIn is
who else do I know who's here so why
don't we build an address book utility
that allows them people to say okay how
do I quickly find out who else do I
knows here upload my dress book I see
who's here we invented that whole
pattern and that caused our growth rate
to go from like two thousand a week to
like I think it was about like twenty
thousand a week
right so and that's you know without
that I don't know if we would have
succeeded maybe other Plan B's would
have worked and then plan Z is what
happens when it's just not working at
all
right it's kind of a lifeboat plant and
that's part of the how you you plan for
both good and bad luck thank you so much
for watching I made this video because
Adam John asked me to so there's a
famous entrepreneur that you want me to
profile next leave it in the comments
below and I'll see what I can do I don't
so love to know what you've reads top
ten rules hit you the hardest leaving
the comments am I gonna join the
discussion thank you so much for
watching continue to believe and I'll
see you soon